Daniel Rostenkowski was a congressman for 36 years. The powerful chairman of one of the most powerful committees-- Ways and Means. But a funny thing happened when he was sentenced to prison for mail fraud. He started to meet people like one young man, 20 years old, who approached him in the exercise yard one day.
丹尼尔·罗斯坦科夫斯基（Daniel Rostenkowski）曾担任国会议员36年。他是最强有力的委员会之一——筹款委员会（Ways and Means Committee）中权势显赫的主席。但当他因邮政欺诈被判入狱时，一件有趣的事情发生了。他开始接触一些人，比如有一天，一个20岁的年轻人走近他在操场上锻炼的区域。
And this young man, a very young, good looking young man, said to me, you know, are you the congressman? Yeah, I am. I said, well, my gosh, what did you do that was so bad? He said, well, I transported drugs. I said, why would you do such a thing? And he said, well, I was going to school and I needed the money. I said, OK. So what was the price that you sought for moving these drugs? He said, I got $10,000. I said, didn't you think that was an exorbitant amount of money to carry a package? Yeah. I said, so you really knew that it was drugs? I mean, I figured that it was. And I said, what was your sentence? He said 17 years. I said, my gosh. First offense.
这个年轻人，一个非常年轻、长相帅气的年轻人对我说：“你是那位国会议员吗？”我说：“是的，我是。”我说：“天哪，你到底做了什么坏事？”他说：“我运输毒品。”我说：“你为什么要干那种事？”他说：“因为我在上学，我需要钱。”我说：“好吧，那么你运送这些毒品的报酬是多少？”他说：“我拿到了1万美元。”我说：“你不觉得运送一个包裹拿到这么多钱太离谱了吗？”他说：“是的。”我说：“那你真的知道那是毒品吗？”他说：“我想应该是吧。”我说：“你被判了多久？”他说：“17年。”我说：“天哪，初犯。”
To put this number in perspective, in federal courts a first time rapist gets five to seven years, kidnappings, four to five years, second degree murder is 11 to 14 years. And here's the thing. The young man was sentenced under a 1980's drug law that Rostenkowski had voted for himself. It set harsh mandatory minimum sentences for drug offenders, even first time offenders. Rostenkowski thought the guy deserved to be punished, but locking him up from the end of adolescence until the beginning of middle age, it seemed excessive.
为了让这个数字更具参考意义，在联邦法院，初犯的强奸犯通常判5到7年，绑架罪判4到5年，二级谋杀罪判11到14年。而关键在于，这个年轻人是根据罗斯坦科夫斯基自己曾投票支持的20世纪80年代的一项毒品法被判刑的。该法案为毒品犯罪者（甚至是初犯）设定了严苛的强制性最低刑期。罗斯坦科夫斯基认为那个年轻人确实该受惩罚，但将他从青春期末尾一直关到中年初期，这似乎太极端了。
The whole thing is a sham in my opinion. It's not justice. It's this get 'em idea.
在我看来，整件事就是个骗局。这不是正义，这是一种“把他们都抓起来”的观念。
Now, the kind of sentencing laws that put him in for so long, can I ask you to explain the terms in which those were discussed among congressmen when those were being talked about? Why were those voted for?
现在，我想请您解释一下，当国会议员讨论这类判刑法时，他们讨论的语境是什么？为什么会投票支持这些法律？
I can't tell you that, I don't remember it. I'm not trying to duck that question but I was totally in a tunnel vacuum vision with my jurisdiction. And I expected out of the Judiciary Committee--
我无法告诉你，我不记得了。我并不是想回避这个问题，但在我的职权范围内，我当时完全处于一种“隧道视野”的盲区。我期望司法委员会——
The committee that made these particular laws?
那个制定这些特定法律的委员会？
--to have the experts in the Judiciary Committee give me the best conclusion. Listening to the debate about these things on the floor of the House of Representatives had nothing to do with it.
——期望司法委员会的专家们能给我最好的结论。在众议院听取关于这些事情的辩论与此毫无关系。
Not long after he got out of prison, Rostenkowski made a speech to lawyers in which he said he voted for these laws because he was quote, "swept along by the rhetoric about getting tough on crime. Few of us had the patience or courage to point out to the public that there was relatively little that changes in federal laws could do to reduce the violent crime in their neighborhood. So we acted, took our low bows, and went on to other topics." As a result, he said, we lock up too many people for too long.
出狱后不久，罗斯坦科夫斯基向律师们发表了一次演讲，他说他投票支持这些法律是因为他引用说“被关于严厉打击犯罪的言论所裹挟。我们中很少有人有耐心或勇气向公众指出，联邦法律的改变对减少其社区内的暴力犯罪作用甚微。所以我们采取了行动，鞠躬谢幕，然后转而讨论其他话题。”结果他说，我们把太多的人关了太久。
And I don't know how to correct it. No member of the legislature that I know of will take this on because it's not popular. And he'll be criticized as being weak in the criminal justice system.
我不知道该如何纠正它。据我所知，没有立法会议员会承担这个责任，因为它不受欢迎。而且他会被批评在刑事司法体系中软弱无能。
Before he was put under investigation himself, Rostenkowski says, he didn't really know about the sentencing guidelines even though he'd voted for them. And in this way, I'd argue, he is more like the rest of us than not. Most of us don't pay much attention to all the laws that are written. We do exactly what Rostenkowski did. We have some vague faith that someone, somewhere, is paying attention. And if something bad is happening, if something unfair is happening, somebody will tell us.
罗斯坦科夫斯基说，在自己被调查之前，他甚至不知道判决指南的存在，尽管他投票支持了它们。我想说的是，从这一点来看，他其实和我们大多数人没什么两样。我们大多数人并不太关注所制定的所有法律。我们做了罗斯坦科夫斯基所做的事。我们有一种模糊的信念，认为某处有人在关注着这一切。如果发生了坏事，或者发生了不公平的事，会有人告诉我们。
What we offer today on our radio program is a study of how that faith failed us and where we've ended up. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass.
我们今天在电台节目中提供的，是对这种信念如何辜负我们以及我们最终走向何方的研究。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
In the last 20 years there's been a radical shift in the way that we sentence people to prison-- mandatory minimum sentences, three strikes and you're out laws, laws bouncing 12 and 13 and 14 year olds into adult court for long adult sentences. Because of all this, the prison population has grown by 50% in less than a decade.
在过去的20年里，我们的监禁判决方式发生了根本性的转变——强制性最低刑期，“三振出局法”，将12、13和14岁的青少年送入成人法庭接受长期成人刑期的法律。正因为这一切，监狱人口在不到十年的时间里增长了50%。
And at some point or another we've all heard news stories about harsh sentences, possibly unfair sentences. And many of us carry a notion somewhere in our heads that maybe some part of this has gone too far. But, you know, who has the time to sit down and figure all of this out?
我们在某个时候都听到过关于严厉刑罚，甚至是可能不公正刑罚的新闻报道。我们许多人脑海中都有一个念头，觉得这其中可能有些地方太过分了。但是，谁有时间坐下来把这一切搞清楚呢？
Well, in today's show we tried to figure it out. And we bring you stories of places where the law seems to be working just fine, where it seems fair, and stories about those areas in which there seem to be some problems. All our stories today are about drug laws.
好吧，在今天的节目中，我们尝试把它搞清楚。我们将为您讲述法律似乎运行良好、显得公平的地方的故事，以及那些似乎存在问题的领域的故事。我们今天所有的故事都是关于毒品法的。
Act One of our program today: What's Wrong With This Picture? The story of how a person could be sentenced to 19 years for drug possession even if police found no drugs, no drug money, no residue, no paraphernalia. Even if it's a first offense.
我们今天节目的第一幕：这张照片有什么问题？讲述一个人即使在警方没有发现毒品、毒资、残留物或吸毒工具的情况下，仅因拥有毒品罪就可能被判19年监禁的故事。即使是初犯。
Act Two: How We Got Here. A firsthand account of how and why Congress wrote these laws in the first place. And believe me, my friend, it is not pretty, from a lawyer who helped draft the laws working for the Congress.
第二幕：我们是如何走到这一步的。一位曾为国会起草过法律的律师，以第一视角讲述了国会为何以及如何制定这些法律。相信我，朋友，这并不好看。
Act One. What's Wong With This Picture.
第一幕。这张照片有什么问题。
This is the story of a case where the law worked exactly as it is supposed to. This is our system working as we have designed it.
这是一个法律完全按照预想运作的案例故事。这就是我们所设计的体系在运作。
Dorothy Gaines was living in Mobile, Alabama, 39 years old, the mother of three children, working as a nursing assistant. The father of her oldest child was a man named Larry Johnson. Dorothy says that she hadn't talked with him in years, that they used to fight over child support. There was bad blood between them. And when he was thrown in prison on drug charges, to get himself a lower sentence he said that she was part of a drug ring.
多萝西·盖恩斯（Dorothy Gaines）住在阿拉巴马州的莫比尔市，39岁，是三个孩子的母亲，担任护理助理。她大孩子的父亲是一个叫拉里·约翰逊（Larry Johnson）的男人。多萝西说她已经好几年没跟他说话了，他们过去常为抚养费争吵。他们之间有积怨。当他因毒品指控被关进监狱时，为了换取较轻的刑期，他说她是贩毒集团的一员。
I always felt like it was a revenge thing. You know, as I read my paperwork and I talk to my attorney, she told me also that he brought up some things against his own mother. So, you know, I didn't know that.
我一直觉得那是一种报复行为。你知道，当我阅读文件并与律师交谈时，她也告诉我，他甚至对他自己的母亲也提出过指控。所以，我不知道这一点。
At the time she and her children were living with a man named Terrell Hines, her common-law husband.
当时她和孩子们与一个叫特雷尔·海恩斯（Terrell Hines）的男人住在一起，他是她的同居伴侣。
He was a working person. A merchant seaman that also came out of the service with honors. But he got caught up into doing drugs. You know, when I saw that he was falling, I did my best to put him in rehab for him to get off drugs.
他是一个勤恳工作的人。他是一名商船海员，服役时还获得了荣誉。但他卷入了吸毒。你知道，当我看到他堕落时，我尽了最大努力送他去戒毒所，想让他戒掉毒品。
Federal investigators came to believe that Dorothy and her husband were part of a conspiracy to move cocaine from Miami to Mobile. She was charged with possession of two kilos of crack cocaine with intent to distribute. Lyn Campbell is Dorothy's current attorney.
联邦调查人员开始认为，多萝西和她的丈夫参与了一个从迈阿密向莫比尔贩运可卡因的阴谋。她被指控持有两公斤可卡因并意图分销。琳·坎贝尔（Lyn Campbell）是多萝西现在的辩护律师。
OK. They searched her house stem to stern and did not find the first hint of residue. And they looked for residue, sandwich bags, cellphone bills, beeper bills, money, hidden guns, hidden--, nothing. And that is incredibly unusual.
好的。他们把她的房子搜了个底朝天，甚至没有发现一丝残留物。他们寻找了残留物、三明治袋、手机账单、传呼机账单、现金、隐藏的枪支、隐藏的……什么都没有。这极其不寻常。
They found no paraphernalia, no drug scales. They found no evidence that she'd ever made any money from the drug business.
他们没有发现吸毒工具，没有发现电子秤。他们没有发现任何证据表明她曾从毒品生意中赚过钱。
There was no evidence introduced that she had any money other than what she got through her meager job and the public assistance her children got. All indications was that she was just living on the edge of poverty.
没有证据表明她除了微薄的工资和孩子们领取的公共补助外有任何其他收入。所有迹象都显示她只是生活在贫困边缘。
How did they decide two kilos, since they never actually found any crack cocaine in her home?
既然他们从未在她家发现过任何可卡因，他们是怎么认定是两公斤的呢？
Well, it was totally based upon, according to the agent that testified, what the kingpin of the conspiracy said. That he had stored a kilo of crack at her house on one occasion. And on another occasion he had brought a kilo through and picked up a kilo of powder from her house that was later converted to crack. So it was totally on what he said.
好吧，据作证的探员说，这完全基于贩毒集团头目的供词。他说有一次在多萝西家藏了一公斤可卡因。还有一次他带了一公斤可卡因过来，从她家取走了一公斤粉末，后来被转化成了可卡因。所以这完全是基于他说的话。
If that were not true, why would he say that? What's in it for him just to finger her?
如果那不是真的，他为什么要那么说？他指证她有什么好处？
Well, cooperating witnesses get substantial sentencing cuts in the federal system. It's the only real way to get your time reduced. And because he was a leader, and I believe there were some weapons involved with him, he was looking basically at a life sentence. By telling on other people, and by being valuable to the federal government, he ended up with less than 15 years in jail. So he has a big incentive to turn in as many people as he can.
好吧，在联邦体系中，配合调查的证人可以获得大幅减刑。这是减少刑期的唯一真正途径。由于他是领导者，而且我相信他涉及一些武器，他本来面临的是终身监禁。通过举报他人，并对联邦政府有价值，他最终只坐了不到15年的牢。所以他有巨大的动力去尽可能多地供出其他人。
Because there was no physical evidence implicating Dorothy, her case had been dropped in state court. But the federal rules are different. In federal court you don't need physical evidence. And the federal drug law has another provision that hurt Dorothy Gaines. It says that if you have knowledge of a conspiracy, or benefit from a conspiracy, or have some tiny role in a conspiracy, you can be accused of all the drugs involved in the conspiracy. So even if you just carry an unmarked package from one side of town to another once, you could be charged with the same amount of drugs as the person who ran the whole operation for years.
由于没有任何物证证明多萝西有罪，她的案子在州法院被驳回了。但联邦规则不同。在联邦法院，你不需要物证。联邦毒品法还有另一条损害了多萝西·盖恩斯的规定。它说，如果你了解一个阴谋，或者从一个阴谋中受益，或者在阴谋中扮演了微小的角色，你就会被指控涉及阴谋中的所有毒品。所以即使你只是帮人把一个未标记的包裹从城镇的一边带到另一边一次，你被指控的毒品数量也可能和那个运营了整个运作多年的人一样多。
Dorothy fought the charges. She says she didn't do anything wrong. And she says they have no  real evidence against her, just the testimony of a bunch of admitted drug dealers.
多萝西对指控进行了抗争。她说她没做错任何事。她说他们没有任何针对她的真实证据，只有一群自认是毒贩的人的证词。
I got the longest time of anybody in the trial, 19 years and seven months.
在审判中，我被判的时间最长，19年零7个月。
And I understand that the guy who is accused of running the drug ring and who had admitted to a lot of the charges against him, and who had a previous record, that he's actually going to get out eight years before you will.
而且我了解到，那个被指控运营贩毒集团、承认了针对他的许多指控且有前科的人，实际上比你早八年出狱。
Exactly.
没错。
And did you have a previous record going into this?
你在涉案前有前科吗？
I had no record.
我没有任何记录。
So what do you make of that?
那你对此怎么看？
I mean, I'm still trying to deal with this emotionally. I still try to deal with it every day, that I got 19 years and seven months on what somebody said I done. No evidence, and all these other people had evidence against them.
我是说，我还在试图从情感上处理这件事。我每天都在尝试面对这个事实，仅仅因为别人说我做了，我就被判了19年零7个月。没有证据，而所有其他人都掌握了针对他们的证据。
When I got sentenced on that date, my kids were there at the courtroom with me. And when the judge said-- he didn't say 19 years, he said 235 months, and I just couldn't function. I mean, I reached over and I asked my attorney, I said, what did he say? He said 235 months. And I said, what is 235 months, because I just couldn't think. And he said it's 19 years and seven months.
在那天宣判时，我的孩子们和我一起在法庭上。当法官说——他没有说19年，他说的是235个月，我当时完全没法思考。我是说，我转过身问我的律师，我说，他说了什么？他说235个月。我说，235个月是多少年？因为我当时脑子一片空白。他说那是19年零7个月。
And, I don't know, I just lost it. All I could hear were my kids screaming in the background. And when the marshals took me out, one of the lady marshals was crying. And I said what's wrong? She said, to see your son hold onto the judge and tell him that my mother's all I got, don't send her away. She said that was the most hurting thing.
然后，我不知道，我崩溃了。我只能听到我的孩子们在背景里尖叫。当法警把我带出去时，其中一位女法警在哭。我说怎么了？她说，看到你的儿子抓住法官，告诉他妈妈是我唯一的依靠，不要把她送走。她说那是让人最心碎的事。
The U. S. Attorney's Office in southern Alabama, which is the office that prosecuted Dorothy Gaines, declined to be interviewed on tape for this story. But a prosecutor acting as a spokesman for that office told us over the phone that the office still contends that she's guilty, that her conviction has withstood several appeals. And as for her 19-year prison term, the prosecutor said that when he began his job, he thought sentences like this were unfair. But now that he's seen the devastation that crack cocaine has on families' lives, he thinks they're justified. He reiterated this several times.
负责起诉多萝西·盖恩斯的南阿拉巴马州联邦检察官办公室拒绝就此故事接受录音采访。但该办公室的一位发言人通过电话告诉我们，办公室仍然坚称她有罪，她的定罪已通过多次上诉。至于她19年的刑期，检察官说，当他刚开始工作时，他认为这样的判决是不公平的。但现在，既然他看到了可卡因对家庭生活的毁灭性影响，他认为它们是合理的。他多次重申了这一点。
One of the jurors in Dorothy Gaines' case told a reporter that, while he thought that she deserved a few years in prison, he was flabbergasted that she got 19. It was possible for him to be surprised because, in federal cases like this one, the jurors only determine guilt or innocence. They aren't present for sentencing. Sentencing is done by judges who have to follow federal sentencing guidelines.
多萝西·盖恩斯案的一名陪审员告诉记者，虽然他认为她确实应该坐几年牢，但19年让他感到震惊。他之所以会感到惊讶，是因为在像这样的联邦案件中，陪审员只决定有罪或无罪。他们不参与量刑。量刑是由必须遵循联邦量刑指南的法官完成的。
And at sentencing, the rules of evidence are much looser than they were during the trial-- testimony that never made it to the witness stand, things that were said to police but never entered into evidence, incredibly, even past charges that you've been accused of and found innocent of in other trials. These can all be used against you during sentencing. And it is at this point in the process, when the rules are so loose, that the court decides the amount of the drugs you'll be charged with. A tiny amount will mean a smaller sentence. A greater amount can mean decades in prison. Again, Dorothy's attorney Lyn Campbell.
而在量刑时，证据规则比审判期间宽松得多——从未走上证人席的证词、告诉警察但从未被作为证据提交的事物，甚至是你曾在其他审判中被指控但被判无罪的事项，这些都可以用在量刑中。正是在这个过程中，在规则如此宽松的时候，法院决定了你被指控的毒品数量。少量的毒品意味着较轻的刑期。较大的数量可能意味着几十年的监禁。再次请出多萝西的律师琳·坎贝尔。
I'm in the system a lot. I think the biggest abuse we still have is the amounts get puffed because--
我在体系里待了很久。我认为我们仍然面临的最大滥用是数量被夸大了，因为——
The quantities of drugs.
毒品的数量。
The quantities, they get puffed up.
数量，它们被夸大了。
What's the sign that things are getting puffed up? What do you usually see that makes you think that it's puffed up in a particular case?
什么迹象表明事情被夸大了？你通常看到什么会让你认为某个特定案件被夸大了？
Well, you might have somebody caught with, let's say, an ounce of crack. They're busted red handed. They've got an ounce on them. By the time they get to sentencing they're being held accountable for, let's say, a kilo and a half, which maxes them out. But you have to understand, when you convert kilos to pounds, just to make the illustration better, a kilo is 2.2 pounds. Each pound has 16 ounces. So you're talking, in essence, of 31 phantom ounces.
嗯，你可能会遇到一个人被抓时，比如说只有一盎司可卡因。他们被当场抓获。他们身上有一盎司。到量刑时，他们要对，比如说，一公斤半负责，这让他们达到了最高刑罚。但你必须明白，当把公斤转换为磅，为了让例子更形象，一公斤是2.2磅。每磅有16盎司。所以你本质上是在谈论多出来的31盎司“幽灵”。
How do they get boosted from one ounce to 2.2 pounds?
他们是怎么从一盎司被提升到2.2磅的？
It's what somebody says. If somebody says, oh, Fred brought in a ki, boom, there you go.
这就是别人说的话。如果有人说，哦，弗雷德带了一公斤，砰，就这样。
And then what kind of sentence are they looking at?
那他们面临什么样的刑期？
Well, depending on their criminal history, if they're somebody like Dorothy, they're looking at 19 years seven months, provided there are no guns and they're not supervising anybody. So, I mean, actually you could get 360 to life on a first offense, 30 to life. And life in the federal system is life. You come out in a box. There is no parole.
嗯，根据他们的犯罪历史，如果是像多萝西这样的人，他们面临的是19年7个月，前提是没有枪支且没有监督任何人。所以，实际上，初犯就可能被判360个月到终身监禁，或者30年到终身监禁。而在联邦体系中，终身监禁就是终身。你只能在棺材里出来。没有假释。
Nearly 2/3 of all federal drug offenders across the country have never been convicted of a violent crime. 40% are first-time offenders. It's tens of thousands of people.
全国近三分之二的联邦毒品犯罪者从未因暴力犯罪被定罪。40%是初犯。那是成千上万的人。
Here's something else about federal drug law. There is a randomness to the way that it's enforced. Whether you're accused has a lot to do with where you live. Dorothy Gaines had the bad luck to live in a federal district that very aggressively targets drug offenders. Southern Alabama, where the largest city is Mobile, population 300,000, convicted roughly the same number of federal drug offenders in 1998 as all of Los Angeles, population 3.5 million.
关于联邦毒品法还有一点。它的执行方式具有随机性。你是否被指控在很大程度上与你居住的地方有关。多萝西·盖恩斯倒霉地住在一个非常激进地针对毒品犯罪者的联邦区。南阿拉巴马州，其最大的城市莫比尔人口30万，在1998年定罪的联邦毒品犯罪者人数与人口350万的整个洛杉矶大致相当。
Federal drug enforcement also tends to disproportionately prosecute minorities. They made up 73% of federal drug convictions in 1998 , even though 72% of illegal drug use is by white people. The federal penalties are much more severe for crack cocaine than for other drugs.
联邦毒品执法也倾向于不成比例地起诉少数族裔。尽管72%的非法毒品使用者是白人，但他们在1998年的联邦毒品定罪中占了73%。联邦对可卡因的处罚比其他毒品严厉得多。
This is reporter Sam Hodges, who first wrote about Dorothy's case in the Alabama Mobile Register.
这位是记者萨姆·霍奇斯（Sam Hodges），他最初在阿拉巴马州的《莫比尔记事报》上报道了多萝西的案子。
It's just clear that a very high percentage, an extremely high percentage, of those who are convicted for crack, which carries the longest sentences of all, are black people. And if you're in a federal judicial district where crack is the focus, as it has been in south Alabama-- and a lot of crack cases end up in federal court as opposed to state court-- then you're really up against it. I mean, your odds of ending up with one of these very long no-parole sentences go up pretty dramatically. And I think that's the environment in which Dorothy Gaines was caught up.
显而易见的是，那些被判持有可卡因（所有毒品中刑期最长的）的人中，绝大多数，极高比例的人是黑人。如果你身处一个以可卡因为重点的联邦司法区，就像南阿拉巴马州那样——而且许多可卡因案件最终进入了联邦法院而不是州法院——那么你真的处境艰难。我的意思是，你最终获得这些长期无假释刑罚的几率会急剧上升。我认为这就是多萝西·盖恩斯所处的环境。
In the end, her 19 year prison term was higher than the federal mandatory minimum sentence for rape, for kidnapping, for running a slave trade, for criminal sexual abuse of a child, for second degree murder, for conspiracy to commit murder. Her sentence had the same minimum as she would have gotten if she had hijacked a plane or bought and sold children for use in pornography.
最终，她19年的刑期比强奸、绑架、贩卖人口、虐待儿童、二级谋杀、谋杀共谋的联邦强制性最低刑期还要长。她的刑期与劫持飞机或买卖儿童用于色情活动的最低刑期相同。
You have mothers in prison that-- all you're doing now is bringing up children to be bitter against the government. I mean, my son is very bitter. And I know I never saw that in him when I was home. This law has destroyed families.
你有很多母亲在监狱里……你现在所做的只是把孩子们培养成对政府充满怨恨的人。我的意思是，我的儿子非常怨恨。我知道当我在家时，我从未在他身上看到过这些。这项法律毁了家庭。
And how old were your kids before you went in?
你入狱前你的孩子们多大？
My daughter, my oldest daughter, Natasha, was 19 years old. My son, Phillip, was 9 And my daughter Chara was 11.
我的女儿，大女儿娜塔莎（Natasha），当时19岁。我的儿子菲利普（Phillip），9岁。我的女儿查拉（Chara），11岁。
And how are they doing?
他们现在怎么样？
Right now they're not doing well. Phillip is incarcerated himself. He's 14. He tried to kill himself twice. Right now they're trying to get him psychiatric help. He had tried to come where I was and he was stopped by the police officer. Ever since I've been incarcerated he always said that he wanted to go to prison to join me. And I always explained to him that even if he get locked up, we won't be together.
现在他们情况不好。菲利普自己也被关进了监狱。他14岁。他自杀过两次。现在他们正试图为他寻求心理帮助。他曾试图到我所在的地方，但被警察拦住了。自从我被监禁以来，他总是说他想去监狱和我团聚。我总是向他解释，即使他被关起来，我们也不会在一起。
Right. You're in a different facility.
对。你在不同的机构。
Yes, I'm in Marianna Camp.
是的，我在玛丽安娜营地（Marianna Camp）。
And how were they doing before you were indicted?
在你被起诉之前他们过得怎么样？
Before I was incarcerated my son was an honor student. He's failed every year since I've been incarcerated now.
在我入狱之前，我的儿子是荣誉学生。自从我入狱以来，他每年都挂科。
He was an honor student?
他是荣誉学生？
He was an honor student. He was on the honor roll.
他是荣誉学生。他上过荣誉榜。
And your daughter?
那你的女儿呢？
She tried going to college but after this it was so hard on her trying to go to school and take care of the kids. She was on the Dean's honor list. And she had to quit college because of this, to take care of the kids, because she didn't want anything to happen to them.
她尝试上大学，但这之后太难了，又要去学校，又要照顾孩子们。她曾名列院系荣誉榜。为了照顾弟弟妹妹，她不得不辍学，因为她不想让他们发生任何意外。
You must feel like all the work you put into raising them is just--
你一定觉得你为抚养他们所做的一切努力都——
It's just down the drain, right?
全都付诸东流了，对吧？
Do you think our country's gone a little crazy in trying to crack down on drugs?
你认为我们的国家在严厉打击毒品方面是不是有点疯了？
Yeah the country's gone a little crazy. They need to really check and see what's really going on. I mean, it's outrageous. I never thought that the United States of America would be like this. I always did my pledge. But it's hard now for me to do a pledge now.
是的，这个国家有点疯了。他们真的需要仔细看看究竟发生了什么。我的意思是，这太离谱了。我从未想过美利坚合众国会变成这样。我总是宣誓效忠。但现在我很难再做宣誓了。
You mean the Pledge of Allegiance?
你是说效忠誓词？
Yes.
是的。
Do they try to have you do the Pledge of Allegiance in prison?
在监狱里他们会让你做效忠誓词吗？
No.
不会。
I was going to say.
我还想问这个呢。
They never tried to have me since I've been incarcerated. But, you know, I go to different things and they would say, well, let's do the pledge. It's going to be hard now. But I know through faith I'm going to get out of this. My hopes are very strong.
自从我被关押以来，他们从来没让我做过。但是，你知道，我参加不同的活动时，他们会说，好吧，我们来宣誓吧。现在会很难。但我知道通过信仰，我会走出这一切。我的希望非常强烈。
Dorothy Gaines, she recently lost her last appeal in the Eleventh District Court. She's not yet told her children. She has one final chance and it's a long shot. She is now appealing to President Clinton for clemency.
多萝西·盖恩斯，她最近在第十一巡回上诉法院败诉。她还没告诉她的孩子们。她还有最后一次机会，虽然希望渺茫。她现在正向克林顿总统请求减刑。
[MUSIC-- "RUN ON" BY MOBY]
[音乐——莫比（Moby）的“Run On”]。
Act Two. How We Got To This Point.
第二幕。我们是如何走到这一点的。
It's tempting, when we hear a story like Dorothy Gaines', to think that the tough laws that put her away for 19 years were created by conservative law and order types, Republicans. And it would be nice to believe that part of the motivation for the loss is idealism. There is, after all, a reasonable case to be made for getting tough on criminals. But in fact, the drug laws that did in Dorothy Gaines were not created by Republicans but by Democrats. And as for how much idealism was at work, well, let us examine the history. It is an amazing story that begins in 1986.
当我们听到像多萝西·盖恩斯这样的故事时，很容易认为那些让她被判19年的严厉法律是由保守的法律与秩序类型的人，即共和党人制定的。如果认为这些法律背后的动机是理想主义，那就太好了。毕竟，严厉打击犯罪是有合理理由的。但事实上，导致多萝西·盖恩斯被判刑的毒品法并不是共和党人创造的，而是民主党人。至于其中有多少理想主义成分，好吧，让我们看看历史。这是一个令人惊奇的故事，始于1986年。
1986 was a pivotal year. It was the sixth year of the Reagan presidency.
1986年是关键的一年。那是里根总统任期的第六年。
This is Eric Sterling. In 1986 he was the lead lawyer when it came to drug laws for the House Judiciary Committee, which was about to become a central political battleground. The two sides in this battle: on one side Tip O'Neill and the Democrats, who had the House. On the other side, Ronald Reagan and the Republicans, who had the Senate, the White House, and, you could argue, the hearts of the American people.
这位是埃里克·斯特林（Eric Sterling）。1986年时，他是众议院司法委员会毒品法律方面的首席律师，该委员会即将成为政治战场的核心。这场战斗的双方：一方是众议院多数党领袖蒂普·奥尼尔（Tip O'Neill）和民主党人；另一方是罗纳德·里根和共和党人，他们掌握着参议院、白宫，甚至可以说掌握着美国人民的心。
The bottom line was the Republicans won in 1984 on the crime issue. They had beat up the Democrats. They had attacked the Democrats as soft. Former Vice President Walter Mondale, the Democratic candidate for president, went down in flames.
归根结底，共和党人在1984年的犯罪议题上赢了。他们打败了民主党人。他们攻击民主党人软弱。民主党总统候选人、前副总统沃尔特·蒙代尔（Walter Mondale）惨败。
And so we now come to 1986, a year in which it is possible that the Democrats could retake the Senate, a year in which the stage is being set for the 1988 election, in which Reagan will not be on the ballot. And so in the overall national political calculus, Democrats are looking around for traction.
所以我们现在到了1986年，民主党人有可能重新夺回参议院的一年，为1988年选举铺平道路的一年，而里根不会在选票上。因此，在整个国家政治计算中，民主党人正在寻找杠杆。
And traction just means an issue that they can champion as theirs so as to win people over and get some votes?
杠杆只是意味着一个他们可以作为自己拥护的主题，从而争取人们支持并获得选票的问题？
Precisely. So in June, 1986, at the end of the basketball season, the champion player from the University of Maryland basketball team, Len Bias, signs with the NBA champion team, the Boston Celtics, the team of the home town of House Speaker Tip O'Neill. Bias flies to Boston. He's going to be the hope of the Celtics. Bias flies home. He's celebrating with his friends. And he dies in the middle of the night from an overdose of cocaine of some kind.
正是如此。所以1986年6月，篮球赛季结束后，马里兰大学篮球队的明星球员伦·拜亚斯（Len Bias）与NBA冠军球队波士顿凯尔特人队签约，这支球队是众议院议长蒂普·奥尼尔的家乡球队。拜亚斯飞往波士顿。他将成为凯尔特人的希望。拜亚斯飞回家。他正在和朋友们庆祝。然后他在半夜因某种可卡因过量而死亡。
And a few days --almost immediately-- Congress adjourns. Members of Congress go back to their districts for the July 4 recess. And the Speaker keeps hearing over and over again about, if a man in the peak of his health, a young man of such promise as Len Bias, can die from cocaine, this is the proof of how bad, and dangerous, and evil this drug is and this drug phenomenon is.
几天后——几乎是立刻——国会休会了。国会议员们回到各自的选区进行7月4日的休会。议长不断地听到人们反复说，如果一个处于身体巅峰、像伦·拜亚斯这样有前途的年轻人都能死于可卡因，这就是这种毒品有多糟糕、多危险、多邪恶，以及这种毒品现象有多严重的事实证明。
And this was traction. By the summer of 1986, the national media had also discovered crack cocaine, and was kicking in full force with scare stories about this new menace to society. When Tip O'Neill got back to Washington he bolted into action.
这就是杠杆。到1986年夏天，国家媒体也发现了快克可卡因，并全力报道关于这个新社会威胁的恐慌故事。当蒂普·奥尼尔回到华盛顿时，他立即采取了行动。
The Speaker convened the Democratic leadership, the Steering and Policy Committee, the chairs of the committees, and says we're going to put together an anti-drug bill. It is going to be a Democratic initiative and I want everybody involved. We're going to have a comprehensive anti-drug provision. And I want it out of committees before we go on our August recess, August 14 or 15.
议长召集了民主党领导层、指导和政策委员会、各委员会主席，说我们将制定一项禁毒法案。这将是民主党的倡议，我希望每个人都参与进来。我们将制定一项全面的禁毒条款。我希望在我们要进行8月休会（8月14或15日）之前它能从委员会中出来。
And this set off about a four week stampede. They were told, look, you've got one month to put together your anti-drug agenda and then you're going to go home in the middle of August and you're going to campaign the hell out of that agenda. And we're going to come back in September, we're going to take it to the floor, and we're going to vote on it. And this is what we're going to ride to electoral victory in November. That's the plan.
这引发了大约四周的集体出动。他们被告知，看，你们有一个月的时间来整理你们的禁毒议程，然后你们将在8月中旬回家，你们要大力宣传这个议程。我们将在9月回来，把它提交到议会辩论，我们要投票通过它。这就是我们将利用它在11月赢得选举胜利的计划。这就是计划。
And to make all this happen in four weeks, just how much faster is that than usual?
为了在四周内完成所有这些，这比通常情况下快了多少？
It's warp speed. We squeezed into a month what is typically an 18-month process.
这是超光速。我们将通常需要18个月的过程压缩到了一个月。
So it's a legislative frenzy. And three days before the end of the whole process, a couple of legislators propose this idea-- mandatory minimum sentences, a radical recasting of drug law. If you were caught with drugs it would not matter if you were a first time offender. It wouldn't matter if there were extenuating circumstances. The only thing that would matter is the amount of drugs you were caught with. And then the judge would give you a sentence whose length was imposed by the Congress in these laws.
所以这是一场立法狂潮。在整个过程结束前的三天，几位立法者提出了这个想法——强制性最低刑期，对毒品法的彻底重构。如果你被发现持有毒品，你是否是初犯并不重要。是否有减轻情节也不重要。唯一重要的是你被发现持有的毒品数量。然后法官会给你一个刑期，其长度由国会在这些法律中强加。
But it was being introduced at a point in which there was no longer an opportunity for hearings. We had no hearings. We did not consult with the Bureau of Prisons, or with the federal judiciary, or with DEA, or with the Justice Department, to at least find out from those folks what would be the effect of mandatory minimums. What are appropriate mandatory minimums?
但它的引入是在没有机会进行听证的时候。我们没有听证会。我们没有咨询监狱管理局、联邦司法机构、缉毒局或司法部，甚至没有从那些人那里了解强制性最低刑期的影响。什么是适当的强制性最低刑期？
And the specific minimums that they chose, could you just talk about one for a moment? How off were they? Was it really so bad? Was their judgment really so bad at this point?
而他们选择的具体最低刑期，你能谈谈其中一个吗？它们偏离了多少？真的那么糟吗？他们的判断在这一点上真的那么糟糕吗？
The numbers that we picked in the Judiciary Committee, the 20 grams of crack cocaine, would have triggered a five-year federal minimum. The Republicans in the Senate dropped the 20 grams to five grams and raised the-- from 5 years to 40 years because the Republicans were going to be tougher.
我们在司法委员会挑选的数字，20克可卡因，将触发五年的联邦最低刑期。参议院的共和党人将20克降至5克，并将——从5年提高到40年，因为共和党人要更强硬。
There was, again, no sense of, it's not a large quantity of drugs from a consumption point of view. It's a very small quantity. And these are folks who have really no clear sense of the dynamics of the business enough to make a just determination. When you're just picking a number--
再一次，没有一种意识，从消费的角度来看，这不是大量的毒品。这是一个非常小的数量。而这些人对毒品业务动态的了解确实不够清楚，无法做出公正的决定。当你只是在随便选一个数字——
One member of Congress, when we tried talking in terms of real significant quantities, would say, in our city we never have quantities that much. I can't go back and say I'm doing something about high level traffickers because we don't have high level traffickers-- I think it was from Kentucky-- that are comparable to what you have in New York, or Houston, or Miami, or Los Angeles. I'm going back to my district and I want to be able to bring something to the Chief of Police, who'll say, damn, great, this is going to help us.
当我们在谈论真正重要的数量时，一位国会议员会说，在我们的城市里，我们从来没有那么大的数量。我无法回去说我正在采取行动打击高层贩毒者，因为我们没有像纽约、休斯顿、迈阿密或洛杉矶那样的可以相比的高层贩毒者——我想他是来自肯塔基州。我要回到我的选区，我想向警察局长展示一些东西，他会说，该死，太棒了，这会帮助我们。
Among the staff and among the chairman of your subcommittee, who was usually very deliberate in hearing all sides, and wanting to gather evidence, I mean, did people turn to each other and just say, what are we doing?
在工作人员和你们的委员会主席中间——他通常在听取各方意见和收集证据方面非常审慎——大家会转过头问对方，我们在做什么吗？
No, not in this case. There's a way in which rhetoric crowds out rationality. If you're a member of Congress and you've spent a lot of time dealing with the minutia of various arcane federal programs, it's not simply a breath of fresh air, it's really intoxicating to talk about the issue of drugs with its good versus evil clarity. It's like you can loosen up your tie. You can start pounding the table. And you know you can connect with your constituents when you start talking about the scourge of drugs, the menace of drugs, the danger that our children face, the epidemic, the pandemic.
不，在这种情况下没有。修辞有时候会挤掉理性。如果你是一名国会议员，你已经花了很多时间处理各种神秘的联邦计划的琐事，谈论毒品及其善恶对决的清晰性，不仅仅是一股清新的空气，这确实令人陶醉。就像你可以松开领带。你可以开始捶桌子。你知道当你开始谈论毒品的祸害、毒品的威胁、我们的孩子面临的危险、疫情、大流行病时，你可以与你的选民建立联系。
You are saying, in a way, that anti-drug rhetoric is like a drug.
你在某种程度上是在说，禁毒修辞就像一种毒品。
Yes, that's right. Barney Frank called one of these issues the crack cocaine of politics.
是的，没错。巴尼·弗兰克（Barney Frank）把这些问题中的一个称为政治的可卡因。
And while these laws were being rushed through Congress, there was actually a commission of sober minded people, Democrats and Republicans, trying to figure out a fair solution to sentencing all federal crimes. And they were doing all the things that Congress was not doing. They were going over statistics, they were talking to prison officials and to police and to judges. And this commission was set up just two years before by Congress itself. And it was due to present its comprehensive overhaul of all sentencing in just a year.
而在这些法律在国会匆忙通过时，实际上有一个由冷静的人士组成的委员会，包括民主党人和共和党人，试图找出对所有联邦犯罪量刑的公平解决方案。他们正在做国会没有做的所有事情。他们正在审查统计数据，正在与监狱官员、警察和法官交谈。这个委员会是国会本身在两年前设立的。它原定于一年内提出其全面的量刑改革方案。
Congress ignored all that. Congress also ignored an order rather relevant bit of recent history, which is that Congress had already tried mandatory minimum sentences for drug crimes back in the 1950s this exact solution, and it didn't work. Drug use went up. So in the 1970s they repealed all those laws.
国会无视了这一切。国会也无视了最近历史中一个相当相关的片段，即国会早在20世纪50年代就已经尝试过毒品犯罪的强制性最低刑期，正是这个完全相同的解决方案，但它没有奏效。毒品使用量增加了。所以在70年代，他们废除了所有这些法律。
But there must have been a point where somebody said, well, you know, we tried this with drug policy back in the '50s and then overturned it in the '70s because it wasn't working?
但一定有过某个时刻，有人说，好吧，你知道，我们在50年代尝试过这种毒品政策，然后在70年代推翻了它，因为它没有奏效？
I don't even know that that was raised in any more than an aside or in a paragraph in a background memorandum. It was, at that point, simply not a consideration. It didn't matter. We were going ahead with this.
我甚至不知道这个问题是否被提及过，除了作为附带提问或背景备忘录中的一段话。在那个时候，这根本不是一个考量。这无关紧要。我们要继续推进这项工作。
In fact, it was such a success that two years later the Democrats did the whole thing again, rushed their way to another set of drug laws in a matter of weeks. And this is where they added one of the rules that did in Dorothy Gaines-- the law that any low level person who is judged to be part of a conspiracy, they can be sentenced at the same level that the leader of the conspiracy is if they have knowledge of the conspiracy and benefit from it in any way.
事实上，它是如此成功，以至于两年后民主党人又把这一切重演了一遍，在几周内匆忙制定了另一套毒品法。这就是他们增加的一项导致多萝西·盖恩斯被定罪的规则——任何被判定为阴谋一部分的低级人员，如果他们了解该阴谋并从中受益，他们可以被判处与阴谋头目相同水平的刑期。
You know, your brother was going to buy you a new set of shoes or you were going to get some money or some benefit. If you have some stake in it, that is sufficient to involve you in the conspiracy. And if you're involved in the conspiracy, you're liable for the whole thing. A very profound change, again without any kind of hearings. I don't think people were paying attention to what the consequences were going to be, and it just passed.
你知道，你兄弟要给你买一双新鞋，或者你要得到一些钱或利益。如果你在其中有股份，那就足以让你卷入阴谋。如果你卷入了阴谋，你就得为整件事负责。这是一个非常深刻的变化，同样没有任何听证会。我不认为人们关注到会产生什么后果，它就这样通过了。
When you would talk to members of Congress privately, what was your feeling about it? Did most of them actually believe the anti-drug rhetoric that they themselves were saying? There's a difference when you think about somebody doing something like passing this kind of law if you believe they're doing it idealistically-- that is, they truly believe that drugs are a scourge and someone must do something-- and doing it cynically, where they feel like well, maybe it's a scourge and maybe it's not, but basically this is what I have to do to stay in office. This is what it means to stay in business.
当你私下与国会议员交谈时，你的感觉是什么？他们中的大多数人真的相信他们自己所说的禁毒修辞吗？当你想到有人做像通过这种法律一样的事情时，如果你相信他们是以理想主义的方式行事——也就是说，他们真正相信毒品是祸害，某人必须做点什么——或者以愤世嫉俗的方式行事，即他们觉得，嗯，也许它是祸害，也许不是，但基本上这是为了留任我必须做的。这就是留任意味着什么。两者之间是有区别的。
I was never able really to have those kinds of honest conversations with members. To ask a question like that is too close to asking are you really gay, or-- I mean, we're talking about an extremely sensitive subject. I would say that the overwhelming majority of members of Congress believe that drugs really are a scourge.
我真的从来没有能够与议员们进行那种诚实的谈话。问那样的问题太接近于问你是不是真的同性恋，或者——我的意思是，我们在谈论一个极其敏感的话题。我会说，绝大多数国会议员相信毒品确实是一种祸害。
But they also, at one level think, well, there's nothing we can really do about it except continue to get tougher. And I fault them for that. Our challenge with drugs is how to deal with this phenomenon that is an important part of our society, an important part of our economy, in a way that the system itself is not causing more wreckage than the drugs themselves are.
但他们也在某种层面上认为，好吧，除了继续严厉打击之外，我们真的无能为力。我为此指责他们。我们面对毒品的挑战是，如何以一种系统本身不会造成比毒品本身更多破坏的方式，来处理这种作为我们社会重要组成部分、作为我们经济重要组成部分的现象。
But to take the other side of it, crime is going down in cities all across the country. The domestic effect of these laws is that crime is going down. People feel safer.
但从另一面来看，全国各城市的犯罪率都在下降。这些法律的国内影响是犯罪率正在下降。人们感到更安全了。
But dope dealing is not especially going down. I mean, we're talking about a specialized type of law, the drug laws. You know, it is still extremely easy for anybody who wants drugs in America to get them. I mean, the real irony is that this is the one category of crime that keeps increasing. We have almost twice as many arrests for drug crimes now as we did when these laws were passed.
但毒品交易并没有特别减少。我的意思是，我们在谈论一种专门的法律，毒品法。你知道，在美国，任何想要毒品的人依然极其容易得到它们。我的意思是，真正的讽刺是，这是唯一一个持续增加的犯罪类别。我们现在因毒品犯罪被捕的人数几乎是我们通过这些法律时的两倍。
Eric Sterling quit his job with the House Judiciary Committee, disturbed over the kinds of drug laws that they were making, and created the Criminal Justice Policy Foundation, an organization that is trying to get Congress to change those laws. He now heads the organization.
埃里克·斯特林因对他们制定的毒品法律感到不安而辞去了众议院司法委员会的工作，并创建了刑事司法政策基金会，这是一个试图让国会改变这些法律的组织。他现在负责该组织。
We invited the two leading supporters of these tough drug laws in Congress to come on to our program and give their side of all this. Both of them, Republican Representative Bill McCollum and Senator Orrin Hatch, both said no despite repeated phone calls and faxes. We were also turned down by another supporter of these laws, Senator Mike DeWine of Ohio. And two senators' offices simply never returned our calls inviting them onto the show-- that's Republican senators Spencer Abraham of Michigan and John Ashcroft of Missouri.
我们邀请了国会中这些严厉毒品法的主要支持者来到我们的节目，陈述他们对这一切的看法。他们两人，共和党众议员比尔·麦科勒姆（Bill McCollum）和参议员奥林·哈奇（Orrin Hatch），尽管我们多次拨打电话和传真，但都表示拒绝。我们还被这些法律的另一位支持者、俄亥俄州的参议员迈克·德瓦恩（Mike DeWine）拒绝了。而两位参议员的办公室干脆没有回复我们邀请他们上节目的电话——他们是密歇根州的共和党参议员斯宾塞·亚伯拉罕（Spencer Abraham）和密苏里的约翰·阿什克罗夫特（John Ashcroft）。
Coming up, we hear about all the places where drug law seems to be working fairly. And judges, we've got judges. That's in a minute from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来的节目，我们将听到关于所有毒品法似乎运行得相当公平的地方。还有法官，我们有法官。那将在国际公共电台的一分钟后，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Sentencing, stories of where our laws may have gone too far in the war on drugs and where they seem to be working just fine. We've arrived at Act Three of our program.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周在节目中都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种不同种类的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是“量刑”，讲述我们的法律在禁毒战争中可能走得太远的地方，以及它们似乎运行得很好的地方。我们已经到达了节目的第三幕。
Act Three: Who Watches the Watchman?
第三幕：谁来监督监督者？
Many people within the judicial system have turned against the harshness and inflexibility of current US drug sentences. The nation's chief law enforcement officer on the drug issue. US Drug Czar Barry McCaffrey, has come out against them, saying they are too strict and ineffective because of that. 86% of all federal judges-- this includes both Republican and Democratic appointees-- say that they want more flexibility to give fair sentences in drug law.
司法系统内的许多人已经转向反对当前美国毒品刑罚的严厉和不灵活。美国毒品问题首席执法官、美国毒品管制局局长巴里·麦卡弗里（Barry McCaffrey）也站出来反对它们，称它们太严格且因此无效。86%的联邦法官——包括共和党和民主党任命的法官——表示他们希望有更多的灵活性，以便在毒品法中给出公平的刑罚。
All 12 federal judicial districts have passed a resolution asking Congress to reconsider the wisdom of the current laws. Dozens of senior federal judges have refused to hear any more drug cases. Judge Morris Lasker of the Southern District of New York, a veteran of over 30 years on the bench, stopped hearing drug cases for a couple of years.
所有12个联邦司法区都通过了一项决议，要求国会重新审视当前法律的智慧。数十位资深联邦法官拒绝再审理任何毒品案件。纽约南区联邦法官莫里斯·拉斯克（Morris Lasker），一位在法官席上拥有超过30年经验的资深人士，曾停止审理毒品案件几年。
It's with regard to the drug cases that I think the greatest injustices take place. They're almost all nonviolent offenses. They carry very substantial sentences. Those were the cases I didn't want to touch. I don't find it so hard to send somebody to prison for a violent crime.
正是关于毒品案件，我认为发生了最大的不公。它们几乎都是非暴力犯罪。它们背负着非常沉重的刑罚。那些是我不想触碰的案件。对于暴力犯罪，将某人送进监狱对我来说并不难。
Judge Terry Hatter is the Chief US District Judge for the Central District of California. He says that under the current federal guidelines, 60% of the time he has to play word games-- that's how he put it-- word games to get to a fair result. 20% of the time he says his final ruling is not the sentence he believes would be the right sentence, given the facts.
特里·哈特（Terry Hatter）法官是加利福尼亚中区联邦地区首席法官。他说，根据现行的联邦指南，他有60%的时间不得不玩文字游戏——这就是他的说法——玩文字游戏才能得到一个公平的结果。20%的时间他说他的最终裁决不是他认为符合事实的正确刑罚。
A big part of the problem, he says, is that because the sentences are set for each crime when the prosecutor chooses what crime to charge a person with, the prosecutor is in effect choosing the sentence. And it turns out there are lots of cases where a person could be charged one way or another, for a more severe crime or a less severe one.
他说，问题的一个很大原因在于，由于每项犯罪的刑期是在检察官选择起诉罪名时设定的，检察官实际上是在选择刑期。事实证明，有很多案件一个人可能以这样或那样的方式被起诉，可能面临较重的罪名或较轻的罪名。
We had two young women. Both young women were living in Mexico City. They were mothers of toddlers. They had been used, sadly, by their respective spouses and they were asked to bring some drugs into this country. And they were caught coming into the country. And what happened under the sentencing scheme was that the drugs were combined even though the women were traveling on their own tickets. They counted the drugs collectively.
我们有两个年轻女性。两位年轻女性都住在墨西哥城。她们是蹒跚学步孩子的母亲。她们不幸地被各自的配偶利用，被要求把一些毒品带进这个国家。她们在进入国家时被抓获。在量刑计划下发生的情况是，尽管女性是各自持有车票旅行的，但毒品被合并计算了。她们集体计算了毒品数量。
Is that because they could be seen as part of a conspiracy?
这是因为她们可以被视为阴谋的一部分吗？
Yes, that's right. And of course they didn't have to be charged that way but they were. And since they were, then they were faced with 10-year mandatory minimums.
是的，没错。当然，她们不必以那种方式被起诉，但她们确实被起诉了。既然被起诉了，那么她们就面临10年的强制性最低刑期。
A young prosecutor has the ability, which I don't have as a presidential appointee confirmed by the United States Senate, serving for life. I don't have that. But the young prosecutor can make a motion to go below the mandatory minimum on the basis of substantial assistance being provided to the government.
一位年轻的检察官有我作为参议院确认、终身任职的总统任命官员所没有的能力。我没有这个能力。但年轻的检察官可以根据向政府提供实质性协助的理由，提出低于强制性最低刑期的动议。
In other words, the prosecutor, if he says that these women have helped us out, he can change the charge so that the women's sentence would change?
换句话说，如果检察官说这些女性帮助了我们，他可以改变指控，从而改变女性的刑期？
What he can do do then is trigger my ability, then, to go below the mandatory minimum.
他能做的就是触发我低于强制性最低刑期的能力。
But you as  the judge--
但你作为法官——
But I can't do it myself, no. only the prosecutor can do that. I intended to give them harsh sentences just because they were involved in drug dealing, two or three years perhaps. But as it turned out, when they came back for sentencing, I said to the young female prosecutor, are you going to make a motion for downward departure? And she said no.
但我自己不能做，不。只有检察官能那样做。我本来打算给她们严厉的刑罚，仅仅因为她们参与了毒品交易，也许两三年。但结果是，当她们回来接受量刑时，我对那位年轻的女检察官说，你会提出向下偏离的动议吗？她说不。
It wasn't that the witnesses had not cooperated. The prosecution agreed that they had. They told everything they knew. They were truthful. It was just that they did not know that much. They did not have much information to give. They were at the bottom of the drug hierarchy, not that useful to the government's investigations
并不是证人没有配合。控方同意她们已经配合了。她们交代了她们所知道的一切。她们很诚实。只是她们知道的并不多。她们没有太多信息可以提供。她们处于毒品等级的底层，对政府的调查没有太大用处。
Judge Hatter felt that was unfair. The women had cooperated as much as they possibly could. It was not their fault that they had no useful information. So he filed the motion that would allow him to sentence them to fewer years than the guidelines permit. This was unprecedented and, it turns out, against the law. It was overturned on appeal, just another example, says Judge Hatter, of how the prosecutor has more power than he does to determine a person's sentence.
哈特法官觉得那是不公平的。女性已经尽了最大努力配合。她们没有有用信息并不是她们的错。所以他提出了允许他判处她们比指南允许的更短刑期的动议。这是史无前例的，结果证明是违法的。它在上诉中被推翻了，哈特法官说，这只是检察官比他有更多权力决定某人刑期的另一个例子。
Well, that's true in every case. That's true in every case because the prosecutor makes the decision on how to charge that particular case. And dependent upon what the charge is, you know what the sentence is pretty much.
嗯，这在每个案件中都是真实的。这在每个案件中都是真实的，因为检察官对如何起诉那个特定案件做出了决定。取决于指控是什么，你知道刑期几乎是预先确定的。
In the 1993 case United States of America against Johnny Patillo, a Reagan appointee to the bench, US District Judge J. Spencer Letts, was so outraged that he had to sentence a man to 10 years for delivering a package containing drugs to a Federal Express office, that his decision in the case included this.
在1993年的“美利坚合众国诉约翰尼·帕蒂洛（Johnny Patillo）”案中，一位里根总统任命的法官、联邦地区法官J·斯宾塞·莱茨（J. Spencer Letts）感到非常愤怒，他必须判处一名男子因向联邦快递办公室递送装有毒品的包裹而入狱10年，他的裁决包括了这些。
He wrote, it is hard to imagine that there is any other nation in which a convicted rapist with a long and unsavory history of prior misconduct can be sentenced by the judge who presides over his trial to a sentence which will make him eligible for parole in less than three years while defendant, a first time offender with a spotless prior record, stands to be sentenced by a Congress who has never seen him and never judged him, to a minimum sentence of 10 years without the possibility of parole.
他写道，很难想象还有哪个国家，一个有着长期且不光彩的前科记录的强奸犯，可以被主持他审判的法官判处让他有资格在不到三年内获得假释的刑期，而一名初犯、记录清白的被告，却面临着由从未见过他、从未审判过他的国会判处最低10年的监禁，且不得假释。
In my view a criminal justice system that does not require not only those who accuse a criminal, but also those who sentence him, to confront him and publicly acknowledge their acts as their own to his face, is worse than uncivilized, it is barbaric.
在我看来，一种不仅要求那些控告罪犯的人，也要求量刑的人，必须面对他，并当面公开承认他们的行为是他们自己的刑事司法系统，比不文明还要糟糕，它是野蛮的。
Act Four: A Night In Drug Court.
第四幕：毒品法庭的一夜。
So before the show ended we wanted to know, how typical are the horror stories? How typical is a case like Dorothy Gaines'? What happens in a typical drug case? All this hour, up until this point, we've been talking about federal drug laws. And while 20,000 people are convicted each year on federal drug charges, most drug crimes in this country end up in state courts. In 1996 it was 350,000 convictions in state court.
所以在节目结束之前，我们想知道，这些恐怖故事有多典型？像多萝西·盖恩斯这样的案例有多典型？一个典型的毒品案件会发生什么？整个这一小时，直到现在，我们一直在谈论联邦毒品法。虽然每年有2万人因联邦毒品指控被定罪，但这个国家的大多数毒品犯罪最终都在州法院解决。1996年州法院有35万人被定罪。
Some states are known for especially ruthless drug laws, like New York State. But for the most part state drug laws are usually less harsh and less rigid than the federal statutes. Often they include a whole range of creative sentencing options including treatment programs, probation, boot camp.
有些州以特别无情的毒品法而闻名，比如纽约州。但在大多数情况下，州毒品法通常比联邦法规不那么严厉、不那么死板。它们通常包括一系列创造性的量刑选项，包括治疗项目、缓刑、新兵训练营。
So to find out what happens in a typical drug case, This American Life producer Nancy Updike went to state court here in Chicago.
所以为了找出典型的毒品案件会发生什么，我们的制作人南希·厄普戴克（Nancy Updike）来到了芝加哥的州法院。
Chicago deals with its huge caseload of drug crimes by holding court at night. The City decided 10 years ago that rather than build new courtrooms to handle its 40,000 drug cases a year, it would simply open up some of its existing courtrooms at the end of the regular court day, and these rooms would handle only felony drug crimes.
芝加哥通过在晚上开庭来处理其庞大的毒品犯罪案件量。市里10年前决定，与其建造新的法庭来处理每年4万起毒品案件，不如简单地在常规法庭时间结束后开放一些现有的法庭，这些法庭只处理重罪毒品犯罪。
The court day starts up about 4:00 PM. For an hour or so, defendants have been heading up the stairs and into the seven story stone courthouse down on 26th Street in Chicago. Unless you work at 26th Street, this is not a place you end up if your life is going well. As I was walking into the building the other day around 3:30, I passed a black man in his fifties and saw him stop in his tracks, quietly throw up on the pavement, and keep walking.
法庭的一天从下午4点左右开始。一个多小时以来，被告们一直走上楼梯，进入位于芝加哥第26街的一座七层高的石砌法院。除非你在26街工作，否则如果你的生活一切顺利，你不会来到这个地方。前几天我在3点半左右走进大楼时，我经过一个50多岁的黑人，看到他停下脚步，安静地在人行道上呕吐，然后继续走。
The courtroom I sat in on is set up sort of in the round. The judge's desk is a huge curve at the top of the circle. The jury box sits at his right, usually empty. There are very few jury trials in night court. And at the foot of the circle are two tables, one for the prosecutors and one for the public defenders. Behind the lawyers are huge panes of glass, and behind the glass are defendants and their families.
我旁听的法庭是围成一圈设置的。法官的办公桌是圆圈顶部的一个巨大曲线。陪审团席位在他的右侧，通常是空的。夜间法庭很少有陪审团审判。在圆圈的尽头是两张桌子，一张给检察官，一张给公设辩护人。律师们身后是巨大的玻璃窗，玻璃后面是被告和他们的家人。
To picture this courtroom, please don't imagine a majestic, echoey space with fine polished wood like in The Verdict or some John Grisham movie. This room is much smaller and dingier, with fluorescent lights, bland carpeting and 70s paneling on the walls. I'm not allowed to record anything in the courtroom itself. So you'll have to guess at exactly what sound all this bad taste makes. The judge in the courtroom is Daniel Darcy.
要想象这个法庭，请不要想象像《大审判》或约翰·格里森电影中那样有着精致抛光木材的宏伟、有回声的空间。这个房间小得多、脏得多，有着荧光灯、平淡的地毯和墙上70年代的镶板。我不允许在法庭内录音。所以你必须自己猜猜所有这些糟糕品味会发出什么样的声音。法庭的法官是丹尼尔·达西（Daniel Darcy）。
I was born and raised in Chicago on the South Side, enlisted in the Army in 1966, came back home and joined the Chicago Police Department. During my time on the police department I went to undergraduate, graduate school, and law school. I got my law degree--
我在芝加哥南区出生长大，1966年应征入伍，回到家后加入了芝加哥警察局。在警察局工作期间，我读了本科、研究生院和法学院。我获得了法学学位——
Darcy is a serious man with white hair who bears a passing resemblance to Andy Griffith. He calls all the defendants Mister and Miss. He hears about 40 cases a night.
达西是一个严肃的人，有着白发，长相与安迪·格里菲斯（Andy Griffith）有几分相似。他称呼所有被告为先生和女士。他每晚听取大约40起案件。
Most of the cases, 90% of the cases, are either small possession charges or people who are selling two or three packets of cocaine to other people on the street. And the reason is, one, is to support their own habit, or to make a few dollars.
大多数案件，90%的案件，要么是小型持有罪名，要么是人们在街上向他人兜售两三包可卡因。原因是，第一，维持他们自己的毒瘾，或者赚几块钱。
Here's a typical case. Tony Bell was a skinny, 27 year old black man who kept rubbing his head with his hands. He stood in front of the judge with his back to me, and was charged with possession of 2/10 of a gram of crack. Think of a Sweet'N Low packet. That's a gram. 2/10 of that. He had no prior record. The public defender on his case was Pablo Decastro.
这是一个典型的案件。托尼·贝尔（Tony Bell）是一个瘦弱的27岁黑人男子，他一直用双手揉搓着头。他背对着我站在法官面前，被指控持有0.2克快克可卡因。想想Sweet'N Low（一种代糖）的小包。那是1克。0.2克。他没有前科。他案子的公设辩护人是巴勃罗·德卡斯特罗（Pablo Decastro）。
Tony Bell told me that he was standing with several other people out there, which is consistent with the officer's story. That as the officer approached, one of the guys dropped some drugs and everybody scattered but him. We call it the slow runner cases. Everybody ran and Tony Bell got caught.
托尼·贝尔告诉我，他当时和几个其他人站在外面，这与警官的故事一致。当警官接近时，其中一个人扔掉了一些毒品，所有人都散开了，除了他。我们称之为“慢跑者案件”。所有人都跑了，只有托尼·贝尔被抓住了。
When Tony Bell's case was first called, at 10 minutes to five, he said he wanted to go to trial. Judge Darcy said OK, and then put the case off until later to give Pablo a chance to ready his defense. By the time Tony Bell's case was called again an hour later, he'd decided to plead guilty and take two years probation. Pablo said Tony told him he was just tired of waiting and that's why he want to take the plea. The prosecutor on Tony Bell's case, Assistant State's Attorney Mike Hood, didn't buy the idea that Tony was just tired of waiting.
当托尼·贝尔的案子第一次被传唤时，在5点差10分，他说他想进行审判。达西法官说好吧，然后把案件推迟到以后，给巴勃罗一个准备辩护的机会。当托尼·贝尔的案子一个小时后再被传唤时，他已经决定认罪，并接受两年缓刑。巴勃罗说托尼告诉他，他只是厌倦了等待，这就是为什么他想认罪。托尼·贝尔案的检察官、助理州检察官迈克·胡德（Mike Hood）并不买账，认为托尼只是厌倦了等待。
I think Mr. Bell saw the writing on the wall. They didn't have any witnesses. We had a solid case. I think a judge, if he found him guilty at trial, would give him a similar punishment because he has no background. So I don't think he felt he was losing anything by pleading early.
我认为贝尔先生看到了结果。他们没有任何证人。我们有个坚实的案子。我认为如果法官在审判中认定他有罪，会给他类似的惩罚，因为他没有任何背景。所以我认为他没觉得早点认罪会损失什么。
Mike Hood says he believes with all his heart that every person he prosecutes in night court is guilty. And Pablo Decastro, the public defender in Tony's case, doesn't exactly disagree.
迈克·胡德说他全心全意相信他在夜间法庭起诉的每个人都有罪。而巴勃罗·德卡斯特罗，托尼案的公设辩护人，并不完全同意。
One of the old jokes about drug court, as opposed to other assignments in this office, is this is the one place where everybody did it. The only question is the legality of the search.
关于毒品法庭，与这个办公室的其他任务相比，老笑话之一是，这是唯一一个每个人都确实做了的地方。唯一的问题是搜查的合法性。
Is that what you believe?
你相信是这样吗？
Not everybody did it, but there's a lot of motions here more than trials. There's a lot of questions about search and seizure, where you're basically admitting that the drugs were in his pocket. You're just trying to argue that the officer's hand shouldn't have been in his pocket also.
不是每个人都做了，但这里有很多动议，多于审判。这里有很多关于搜查和扣押的问题，你基本上承认毒品在口袋里。你只是试图争论警官的手也不应该放进他的口袋里。
I saw 105 cases in nine hours at night court. Usually what would happen, since almost no one gets in and out of the legal system in one day, is that Judge Darcy would call the case number, some small action would be taken-- a motion or an update on gathering witness testimony-- and then Darcy would put the case off until a later date. This happened in 101 out of the 105 cases I saw. That left four cases, four people who did get sentenced. Three got probation and one guy was sent to prison. He had a record of burglary and had once escaped from prison.
我在夜间法庭9个小时里看了105起案件。通常会发生的是，由于几乎没有人能在一天之内进出法律体系，达西法官会传唤案号，进行一些小的操作——一个动议或关于收集证人证词的更新——然后达西会把案件推迟到以后的日期。我在我看过的105起案件中有101起发生了这种情况。剩下四起案件，四个人确实被判刑了。三个人获得缓刑，一个人被送进了监狱。他有入室盗窃记录，还曾从监狱逃跑。
Now, to see how typical those sentences were, I looked at all the cases from the other five courtrooms for the two nights I sat in on Darcy's room. Here's what I found. There were 343 cases total. 18 got probation and 21 got prison time, most of them less than two years. Five people were recommended to boot camp as an alternative to prison. The longest sentence anyone got on those two nights was six years. Two men ended up with that. One had already been in prison for burglary and sexual assault. The other had done time for robbery and also for, as the law delicately puts it, taking indecent liberties with a child.
现在，为了看看这些判决有多典型，我看了达西房间里我旁听的那两个夜晚其他五个法庭的所有案件。这就是我的发现。总共有343起案件。18人获得缓刑，21人获得刑期，其中大多数不到两年。五个人被推荐参加新兵训练营作为监狱的替代方案。那两个晚上任何人得到的最高刑期是六年。两个人最终得到了那个刑期。一个人已经因入室盗窃和性侵犯入狱。另一个人因抢劫服过刑，也因为，正如法律文雅所说，对儿童进行猥亵行为。
For the whole month I sat in on, August, 149 people were sentenced to probation, about the same number as were sent to prison, 144. Also, fully half of the defendants who asked for a trial in front of the judge were found not guilty, and a significant number of others were found guilty of a lesser crime than the one they had originally been charged with. The statistics for July and September were similar, about an equal number of sentences for probation and for prison time, and at least half of all trials ending in not guilty.
在我旁听的整个月里，即8月，149人被判缓刑，与被送进监狱的人数大致相同，144人。此外，在法庭上要求审判的被告中，整整一半被认定无罪，还有相当多的人被认定犯有比他们最初被指控的罪名更轻的罪名。7月和9月的统计数据类似，缓刑和刑期的判决数量大致相等，至少有一半的审判以无罪告终。
Overall, examining these cases, it seemed fair. Tiny quantities of drugs got probation or short sentences, even for second and third offenses. Large quantities of drugs, but especially a history of violent crime, meant longer sentences. And dealers got more time than people just caught in possession of drugs. Again, overall it seemed like a decent system.
总的来说，检查这些案件，这似乎很公平。少量的毒品获得了缓刑或短期刑期，即使是第二次和第三次犯罪。大量的毒品，尤其是暴力犯罪史，意味着更长的刑期。而毒贩获得的刑期比仅因持有毒品被抓的人要长。再一次，总的来说，这似乎是一个体面的体系。
I had a long talk with Judge Darcy about his position as a state judge versus that of federal judges handling drug crimes.
我和达西法官就他作为州法官与处理毒品犯罪的联邦法官的立场进行了长谈。
I don't think the laws are harsh at all at the state level.
我不认为在州一级法律有多严厉。
So you feel like you have the freedom that you need to give out sentences that you feel are just and fair?
所以你觉得你有足够的自由来给出你认为公正和公平的判决？
Yes I do, absolutely.
是的，我确实，绝对。
Have you ever felt forced to send someone to prison for many more years than you felt was just?
你是否曾经被迫将某人送进监狱，刑期远比你认为公正的要长？
No, no. Well, sometimes some people get caught up in situations that they have no background. And the sentence calls for a minimum of six years.
不，不。好吧，有时有些人卷入了一些他们没有背景的情况。而判决要求至少六年。
So, in other words, it's the first time that they're arrested but they're arrested with a large amount of drugs.
所以，换句话说，这是他们第一次被捕，但他们被捕时携带了大量毒品。
With a certain amount of drugs that, what we call here in state court are facing Class X penalties. And the penalty for a Class X felony, if they're convicted, is 6 to 30 years. And sometimes that doesn't fit the person if they're-- Sometimes two or three years might be good rather than six but, you know, I have to follow the law and that's what I'll do. But that's not normal. Most of the cases that come through here, the sentences are appropriate and the dispositions, I have no qualms with them at all.
带有一定数量的毒品，我们在这里州法院称之为面临X级处罚。对于X级重罪，如果他们被定罪，刑罚是6到30年。有时这不适合那个人，如果他们是——有时两三年可能比六年更好，但你知道，我必须遵循法律，这就是我会做的。但这不正常。通过这里的案件中，大多数判决是适当的，处置结果，我根本没有顾虑。
While the sentences for individual cases seemed fair enough, there was one thing that did not seem fair about night court. Out of 105 cases, almost every single defendant was black, maybe 15 Latinos, three white men. In the other courtrooms it was the same. Out of hundreds of defendants, only a tiny handful were white.
虽然个别案件的判决看起来足够公平，但夜间法庭有一件事似乎并不公平。在105起案件中，几乎每一个被告都是黑人，也许有15个拉丁裔，三个白人。在其他法庭也是一样。在数百名被告中，只有极少数是白人。
It's not that white people charged with drug crimes happened to be coming during the day. The distribution of cases among all the courtrooms, both day and night, is random. And it's not that these courtrooms are just serving black neighborhoods. This building handles all the drug cases for the entire city of Chicago, a city that's only 38% black.
并不是说因毒品犯罪被指控的白人恰好在白天过来。案件在所有法庭（白天和晚上）之间的分配是随机的。而且这些法庭不仅仅为黑人社区服务。这座大楼处理芝加哥整个城市的所有毒品案件，这是一个只有38%人口是黑人的城市。
Let me remind you that 72% of drug users nationwide are white according to the Department of Health and Human Services. In Chicago that works out to 66,000 white drug users. But when it comes to drug arrests, look what happens. In Chicago in 1997, the last year police have compiled data for, 37,000 black people were arrested for drug crimes compared to 9,000 white people. I know these numbers can be kind of hard to follow over the radio, so here's the bottom line. If you're a black drug user in Chicago you have a nearly one in two chance of being arrested. White drug users, one in seven. Anyone who works at night court sees it.
让我提醒你，根据卫生与公众服务部的数据，全国72%的毒品使用者是白人。在芝加哥，这相当于6.6万名白人毒品使用者。但当谈到毒品逮捕时，看看发生了什么。在1997年的芝加哥，警察编译数据的最后一年，3.7万名黑人因毒品犯罪被捕，相比之下只有9000名白人。我知道这些数字在广播里听起来有点难跟上，所以这是结论。如果你在芝加哥是一名黑人毒品使用者，你有近二分之一的机会被捕。白人毒品使用者，七分之一。任何在夜间法庭工作的人都看到了。
I asked judge Darcy what he thought about seeing almost all black defendants night after night, whether it bothers him.
我问达西法官他对每晚看到几乎全是黑人被告有什么看法，这是否困扰他。
When I'm judging people and people are coming in front of me, there is no color line. It doesn't make any difference to me. Now, does it bother me that a certain group are being charged with all those crimes? Yes it does.
当我判断人，人们来到我面前时，没有颜色界限。对我来说没有什么区别。现在，特定群体被指控犯有所有这些罪行是否困扰我？是的，困扰。
I asked Mike Hood, the Assistant State's Attorney who prosecuted Tony Bell, what he thought about seeing practically all black defendants.
我问起诉托尼·贝尔的助理州检察官迈克·胡德，他看到几乎全是黑人被告有什么看法。
It bothers me. I mean, I'm concerned. But I don't really look at it as a-- I'm not prosecuting on race, I'm prosecuting a person for a crime.
这困扰我。我是说，我很关心。但我真的不把它看作是一个——我不是基于种族起诉，我起诉的是一个人犯下的罪行。
What bothers you about it then?
那它有什么困扰你的？
Well, I think what bothers me is that people take notice of that, like you just did.
好吧，我认为困扰我的是人们注意到这一点，就像你刚才那样。
But how can you not? I mean, if you're sitting in the courtroom, you know, there's a court full of mostly white people and then everyone sitting behind the glass is black.
但这怎么可能不注意呢？我的意思是，如果你坐在法庭里，你知道，这是一个坐满了大多是白人的法庭，而所有坐在玻璃后面的人都是黑人。
Let me explain. I meant that it bothers me that people don't look at it as the crime. You take notice of it because you're saying it's an African American here, they're all African Americans. I don't look at that way. My issues are very simple. Two grams of heroin, three transactions, two police officers, three on surveillance, the stuff was inventoried. It's in fact crack cocaine or heroin, a good arrest, that man did it, he's going to go to jail. That's how I look at it.
让我解释一下。我的意思是，困扰我的是人们不把它看作是犯罪。你注意到它是因为你在说这里有一个非裔美国人，他们全是非裔美国人。我不那样看。我的问题非常简单。两克海洛因，三次交易，两名警官，三人在监视，东西被清点。这事实上是可卡因或海洛因，一次好的逮捕，那个人确实做了，他会去坐牢。我就是这么看的。
It's easy to feel, when you hear about drug sentencing in this country, that the justice system is a total mess, as though the system is running us, not the other way around. We feel this way because what we really want from any system is to feel that it's still possible to operate within it as a human being. We want to see someone make an appropriate exception. We want to see someone understand the reality of the rules they're implementing. We want to see someone grasp the intent behind the system and use the system skillfully in the service of that intent.
当你在这个国家听到关于毒品量刑时，很容易感到司法系统是一个彻底的混乱，好像系统在运行我们，而不是反过来。我们有这种感觉，因为我们从任何系统中真正想要的是感受到在这个系统中作为一个人类来运作仍然是可能的。我们想看到有人做出适当的例外。我们想看到有人理解他们正在实施的规则背后的现实。我们想看到有人掌握系统背后的意图，并熟练地利用系统为该意图服务。
I saw all that at night court. I saw Judge Darcy talk to a defendant named, memorably, James Brown, who had been saying for more than a year that he didn't want a public defender, he wanted to hire his own lawyer. Darcy had finally had enough. He wasn't mad, but firm. He leaned forward and said, let me explain this to you. If you don't have an attorney with you next time, this public defender right here is going to stay with you and we are going to set this case for trial. I just want to make that absolutely clear.
我在夜间法庭看到了这一切。我看到达西法官对一个名叫詹姆斯·布朗（James Brown）的被告说话，他已经说了一年多他不想用公设辩护人，他想雇自己的律师。达西终于受够了。他没有生气，但很坚定。他身体前倾说，让我解释一下。如果下次你没有律师和你在一起，这名公设辩护人就在这里，他会和你待在一起，我们要把这个案子定为审判。我只是想把这一点说清楚。
I saw Darcy agree to recommit a kid to probation after he was picked up on a new drug charge and then look the kid in the eye and say, you only get so many chances. Do you understand that? The kid nodded.
我看到达西同意在一个孩子因为新的毒品指控被抓后再次让他缓刑，然后直视那孩子的眼睛说，你只能有这么多次机会。你明白吗？孩子点了点头。
I found out that prosecutor Mike Hood refused to help a cop polish up his testimony, even though it would have been better for Hood's case if he'd done it, even though no reporters were around to find out about it at the time. The cop couldn't remember which kid was which out of the two he'd arrested, and he was confused about where he picked them up. Hood said, so be it, and the kids were acquitted.
我发现检察官迈克·胡德拒绝帮助警察润色他的证词，即使他那样做对他自己的案子更好，即使当时周围没有记者去发现它。警察想不起他逮捕的两个孩子中哪一个是哪一个，他搞不清他在哪里抓住了他们。胡德说，那就这样吧，孩子们被判无罪。
These are small examples, but they demonstrate how it is possible to create a legal system with room for human beings to act like human beings. I think that's what we want from our laws.
这些是小例子，但它们展示了创建一个有空间让人们像人类一样行事的法律体系是可能的。我认为这就是我们从法律中想要的。
Nancy Updike.
南希·厄普戴克。
One postscript to our show today. Congress has not changed its opinion of mandatory minimums. The House and Senate both recently passed the Violent and Repeat Juvenile Offender Accountability and Rehabilitation Act of 1999, which would extend more mandatory minimum sentences to more crimes, and to more crimes involving teenagers. It can go to committee and become law anytime.
我们今天节目的一个附言。国会没有改变其对强制性最低刑期的看法。众议院和参议院最近都通过了《1999年暴力和累犯青少年罪犯问责和康复法案》，该法案将把更多的强制性最低刑期延伸到更多的罪行，以及更多涉及青少年的罪行。它随时可能提交委员会并成为法律。
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and of myself with Blue Chevigny, Alex Blumberg, Susan Burton, and Julie Snyder.
好吧，我们今天的节目由南希·厄普戴克和我本人制作，还有布鲁·切维尼（Blue Chevigny）、亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）和朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Original piano music for today's show was composed and performed by Charles [? Misser. ?] To buy a cassette of this program, call us here at WBEZ in Chicago. 312-832-3380. Or you know you can listen to this or any of our programs for free on the internet. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
今天节目的原创钢琴音乐是由查尔斯·[米瑟？]创作和演奏的。要购买该节目的磁带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台。312-832-3380。或者你知道你可以免费在互联网上收听这个或我们的任何节目。《美国生活》由国际公共电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金赞助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who says after every single show--
WBEZ管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他在每一期节目后都会说——
Bam. Oh my God! What is this all about?
砰。天哪！这一切到底是怎么回事？
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共电台。